[Musik]
bismarck erst ist die blm unique viertel
macht so hallo willkommen und vielen
dank dass sie gekommen sind lassen bei
dem schönen wetter so bleiben dass das
irgendwie lustig weil das ende des
semesters werden wir alle hier sitzen
ins schwitzen weil sie denn jetzt
wirklich heiß sein wird und jetzt
schneit es dort ließ sagt alles in maßen
in der ersten sitzung habe ich schon
angekündigt dass sie nicht nur
philosophen einzelne philosophinnen
besprechen werden sondern auch ab und zu
die ansichten über frauen die wir in der
geschichte der philosophie im
allgemeinen finden allgemein ich hätte
der philosophie ist natürlich geschichte
von philosophen also männliche viele
sorten das ist genau das problem dass
wir hier bekannten und später werden wir
ein bisschen über ansichten frauen im
mittelalter hören wenn wir zeit finden
heute werden wir aber das thema bei den
zwei hauptprotagonisten der klassischen
antiken löse wie wir sprechen nämlich
platon und aristoteles meine meinung
nach die zweigrößte denke alle zeit und
das bespreche ich mit einer gewissen
sorge in dem man weg von dieser
vorlesung freut vielleicht kommen könnte
mit einer schlechteren meinung der zwei
herren
vor allem eines deutlich das wissen
viele von ihnen vielleicht schon dass
alles okay ist dafür verantwortlich ist
nicht nur eine sehr beleidigend theorie
der frauen zu haben sondern auch weil er
natürlich sehr einflussreich war er war
weit mit mit großen großem abstand der
einflussreichsten denker aller zeiten
müssen es in der europäischen situation
und von daher können wir ihn auch wir
können eigentlich auch beschuldigen dass
er dann diese muss man sagen typisch
antike grip anti griechische meinungen
über frauen dann durch die jahrhunderte
dann verbreitet hat weil seine texte so
so wichtig und einflussreich waren
allerdings muss man schon sagen dass
frauen bei ahlers dort ließen nie als
haut thema erscheinen wahrscheinlich die
stellen wo er sich am meisten für
weibliche wesen interessiert hat mit
unbedingt mit menschlichen fahren zu tun
sondern mit weiblichen tieren im
allgemeinen und zwar in seinem
biologischen werke der hat er hat die
wissenschaft der zoologie oder biologie
das hätte ich erfunden und mehrere werke
zur bildung nie geschrieben und da
versucht er zu erklären wie kinder nicht
nur menschliche kinder seien kinder
junge tiere aller art erzeugt werden und
dann müssen natürlich beschreiben welche
rolle die frau spielt das werden wir
auch besprechen
allerdings gibt es dann bei ihnen
methodisch dann vor allem den
praktischen werken in der ethik und vor
allem in der politik wo er dann dieses
thema so gut oder nur flüchtig gesprächs
und diese
es sind mehr oder weniger würden schon
sehr oft intensiv ausgelegt um sozusagen
seine innere gedanken über zum thema
weiblichkeit zu verstehen
das werden wir auch machen
ich werde ein bisschen in die richtung
merken zu zeigen dass alles so wie es
nicht ganz so schlimm ist wie er
vielleicht zu erscheint allerdings werde
ich eigentlich zeigen dass er schlimm
genug ist und und das noch schlimmer
ich habe schon ja sogar überlegt ob ich
zuerst das wort wie es machen soll und
dann warten der nächsten miss kann damit
es nicht ganz so zwingend ist
aber das ist soll ich natürlich falsch
und dann dachte ich egal also jemand
plattform ist und platin ist auch
interessante also wenn ich zeit ein
bisschen davon läuft und ich mich wenn
ich so begeistert das thema spreche ich
würde lieber platon tief besprechen und
erst dort ließ nichts zu tief platon im
gegensatz zu al assad ließ ist dafür
bekannt dass er eigentlich sehr gute
dinge zum thema frauen wie sie gleich
sehen werden der es gibt ausnahmen aber
sehr bekannt ist
das ist wahrscheinlich die kritische
stelle über frauen in der antiken
philosophie vielleicht sogar die
bekannteste stelle über frauen in der
gänzlichen geschichte der flüsse viel
daran hat hat mich daran gedacht und das
wirklich stimmt aber ich denke schon
wahrscheinlichkeit hat jemand ein
anderes beispiel
aber es natürlich die passage in der
politik wo er
erklärt dass frauen nicht nur männer bei
den wächtern des perfekten staates auch
tätig sind und sozusagen in dieser
oberen schicht in dieser perfekten
gesellschaft tätig sind uns vor allem
dass sie als krieger kriegerinnen dienen
sollen und dass sie philosophieren
können also hier haben wir praktisch die
idee das ist nicht nur für die könige
gibt es bei platon zum auch philosoph
königinnen und wenn das nicht toll ist
dann was ist was wäre ganz toll
allerdings werde ich in die richtung ein
bisschen dazu neigen zu zeigen dass
platz war nicht ganz so toll ist wie er
zu sein scheint
obwohl er ziemlich toll ist
aber beginnen würde dafür plädieren und
dass wir immer ein material das ernst
und das ist wirklich also die halte
menschlichen bevölkerung ist nicht so
schön wenn man es so abwehrte wie ja das
doch ließ das tut aber ich würde gerne
dass sie verstecken sie mir bitte dass
sie nicht denken ach diese
frauenfeindliche artist dort ließen
werde ich nie wieder lesen weil das ist
natürlich nur ein aspekt seines denkens
und wenn wir ihnen dafür beschuldigen
dass er frauenfeindlich ist was er
sicherlich war dafür dass er nichts
untypisch war sowie plattform er war
typisch für griechische ein feindlicher
okay so zuerst plattform und frauen
es wäre meiner meinung meiner meinung
nach ganz falsch so sofort zu dieser
passage in der politik so stürzen ohne
zu überlegen das platten frauen auch
anderswo erwähnt und in diesen anderen
passagen wo er was allgemeines über
frauen sagt dass es viel
frauenfeindlicher als das was wir in der
polit er für und das ist wichtig weil es
das bildet einen gewissen zusammenhang
für das was er in der polit er sagt
natürlich kann man wie immer bei karten
im voraus sagen alles was er sagt ist
natürlich nur die behauptung eines
charakters inhalt in einem dialog also
platte erscheint nichts als sprecher und
seinem seinen eigenen werken und zb man
könnte denken dass diese passage aus den
männern die ich gleich zitieren werde
dass es was sicherlich nicht klattens
meinung also die die frauenfeindlichkeit
ist zusammen den männern zu schreiben
platter aber wie auch immer was haben
wir bei platon über frauen außerhalb der
politik
ok erstens wahrscheinlich die
bekannteste stelle weil sie so zu kurz
und so irgendwie so erschütternd ist im
phaidon und das kennen wahrscheinlich
viele von ihnen schon gibt es die szene
ganz am anfang wo soll ich also sorge
dieses wird gleich hingerichtet ja mit
gift also es im gefängnis und wartet
darauf dass er giftig - und seine junge
männliche freunde sind alle da und seine
frau joanne c
und sie weiß und sagt socket hieß was
werden die freunde jetzt machen wenn du
weg bist und ersatz schickt sie weg und
dann wird sozusagen weg gebracht
anscheinend damit sie das service
gespräch nicht stört und wir haben das
als zeichen genommen
das aus platten sicht oder vielleicht
aussage dieses sicht frauen vielleicht
sogar nichts dafür nicht dazu fähig sind
philosophie unter solchen bedingungen zu
treiben und vielleicht deswegen da nicht
wir wissen aus der politik das plateau
nicht dieser ansicht ist aber trotzdem
wenn man so sagen nur diese passage
hätte dann hätte könnte man diesen
eindruck gewinnen dass das ist eine
seite
diese dieser passage eine andere seite
ist vielleicht zu bedenken dass am ende
des scheiterns im gleichen dialog gleich
bevor er stirbt fangen all die männer
die gesprächspartner an zu weinen und
sollte es musste aalen und sagen
hey reißt euch zusammen wir sind noch
finde so für mich mehr oder weniger also
wenn das so sagen wenn man aus der
ersten passage den eindruck gewinnen
könnten nur frauen können sie zudem nur
männer können mindestens unter diesen
sehr schwierigen bedingungen vernünftig
bleiben und philosophieren
man könnte aus der zweiten passage den
eindruck gewinnen nur so kts kann das
war es selbst seine schüler sind nicht
in der lage das zu tun noch eine passage
oder ein aspekt die was sie hier lernen
möchte ist es gibt auch ein diener oder
ein wärter im gefängnis und und sokratis
sagt über ihn wie schön es ist und wie
nett es ist dass er für softies baines
und dass er so sein so viele sorgen um
socke dies macht man hat den eindruck
dass er sozusagen verschiedene
erwartungen hat für all diese
verschiedene leute also für den wächter
hat er überhaupt keine erwartungen
und deswegen ist es schön dass uns
sympathisch ist vielleicht eine
übersetzung von dem was er sagt er ist
sympathisch da dass der wärter weint vor
der mit leipzigs es ist auch nicht von
ccps erwarten dass sie sozusagen cool
bleibt und die unsterblichkeit der seele
spricht
wenn sorgt dies gleich sterben wird
aber es ist doch von den schülern zu
erwarten dass sie das machen und ob das
damit zu tun hat dass sie männer sind
ist wird natürlich hinterfragt aber
andererseits sind sie alle männer
das ist eine passage viel schlimmer weil
weniger kompliziert mindestens aus
unserer hinsicht also thema frau ist die
stimmung im team aus und auch in anderen
dialogen
wir das erklärt dass menschen nach dem
tod wiedergeboren werden und nicht
unbedingt aus menschen
sie können auch als tiere zu bekommen
und zum beispiel auch im weiteren den
mythos kommt eine stelle wo sache dies
behauptet dass zum beispiel ganz
ordentliche leute also gute bürger
sozusagen die kommen als ameisen zurück
wie gut dass sich zufällig des deutsches
das deutsche weise weiß hätte ich
gedacht okay und so weiter also
gewalttätige menschen kommen aus
wolfsburg und und da wird nichts über
weibliche menschen gesagt auch im
senckenberg der polit er wird nichts
nichts also das wird auch nicht
thematisiert obwohl man auch dort
wiedergeburt als thema hat im noch in
einem miethaus eventim aus wie das
ausdrücklich gesagt dass menschen die
sozusagen verdient haben dass sie
bestraft werden dadurch bestraft werden
dass sie als frauen zu bekommen sein
also ich würde schon ausprobieren das
nächste mal
und jetzt
[Musik]
naja okay aber ich mein haus dieser
passat okay ich verstehe was die man
natürlich können sie es gut ausgehen
wenn man amazon wird ist es was sie
meinen
ja da bin ich an der macht er das könnte
es sein aber das wäre sehr großzügig
diese passage gegenüber weil alles was
er sagt ist wenn du wenn du bestraft
werden so dass kommst ausbau zurück und
es scheint dass man das so sagen es gibt
eine biologische skala menschlichen also
männliche menschen weibliche menschen
dann tiere
das ist praktisch was wir angeboten
werden das wäre vielleicht auch ein
gegenargument gegen diese größen wie die
auslegung dass die bedrohung dass man
das tier zurück kommt hat nichts damit
zu tun dass die tiere dann in ein tier
peinliche eine tierfreundliche
gesellschaft kommen offensichtlich aber
gut dass versuche also das ist eine
zweite passage die dritte person die ich
schon erwähnt habe ist er kommt bei dem
in den männern vor
und dass das kennen viele von ihnen das
ist ein dialog hieß mit einem nicht zu
hellen gesprächspartner spricht nämlich
männern und der war schule des gorillas
der berühmte so fest wird dann es wird
von ihm von sokratis verlangt dass er
die tugend definiert damit sollte dies
dann die hand seines mentors frage
beantworten kann ob die tugend der ba
ist und dann versucht man mehrmals die
tuben zu definieren und das erste was er
sagt ist dass es dass es sehr leicht
ich kann dir sagen was die tugend ist
und dann sagt er
willst du die tugenden
das ist eine altmodische übersetzung
das sind die deutschen übersetzungen die
ich schnell
wozu jetzt dazu griff hatte und im
allgemeinen habe ich die sagen immer war
statt frau und das habe ich immer
geändert aber hier dachte dass das
wirklich passt wegen was er sagt willst
du die tugend des weibes so ist auch so
ist auch nicht schwer zu beschreiben
dass sie das haus wesen gut verwalten
muss als im hause gut instand halten und
den manager rechnet und das ist uns
ähnlicher weise zum beispiel die tugend
eines pferdes ist stark zu sein
die tugend eines mannes ist in der in
der polis tätig zu sein und so weiter
die idee ist für jedes lebewesen eine
andrea tugend und da es sehr auffällig
natürlich dass die tugend einer frau
anders ist als die tugend eines mannes
wie gesagt haben wir hier nichts mit
einer äußerung plattform zu tun schon
vielleicht sogar weniger als in meinem
wagen nie mit einem äußeren plattform zu
tun aber hier weniger als sonst sogar
weil das wahrscheinlich nur eine
schilderung der turnlehrer görges ist
wir wissen aus als dass georgiens
behauptet hat dass man die tugend fragt
sich nur in dieser weise definieren
könnte so nicht pauschal sondern die
reihe nach was ist die typen von max und
y und z
und so wie es reagiert sogar darauf dass
er die definition kritisiert war eben
eine einheitliche definition haben will
das genau was er verlangt andererseits
reagiert ein nicht dadurch dass er sagt
das wahlverfahren find ich mein freund
nennen also das kritisiert ja nichts
also das zweite zu sein also er
beschreitet mindestens nichts dass das
zusammen eine treffende äußerung ist zur
weiblichen natur aber er äußert sich zu
dieser
feststellung überhaupt nichts er äußert
sich zu der art definition die
mitgeboten hat mein eindruck ist über
diese passagen einig ist dass erstens
wie gesagt das soll georgi an gollers
erinnern
und zweitens wenn das an sonst irgendwas
für das wenn es sonst merkt zeigt als
nur dass das goldes meinung denn seit es
das ist natürlich die typische
erwartungen ist in der griechischen
antike vor allem in athen über die
aufgabe der fragen was wir sowieso
kosten aus vielen historischen kleinen
die schon zitiert habe also nicht sehr
überraschend und wahrscheinlich sehr
aussagekräftig über die frage was
plattform wirklich über frauen denkt
diese stellen sind in dieser hinsicht
gemeinsam das sozusagen der pumps wollen
nichts was über frauen zu sagen sondern
hat er sonst objekt sonst irgendwas was
ja wir sprechen möchte und fragen kommen
nur als beispiel zum beispiel der
theorie des wieder geburts und sagt man
kann als tier wiedergeboren als mann
oder als frau als frau aus natürlich
schlechter übrigens im voraus denken
zwei wochen
diese hat diese idee dass man als frau
wiedergeboren kann und dass das
schlechte ist haben wir auch in antiken
india indien werden wir auch sehen er
ist eine gemeinsamkeit aber auf jeden
fall in allen drei passagen und man
könnte vielleicht andere beispiele zum
beispiel aus der als den lakers finden
dass eine radierung diese beispiele sind
alle stellen wo er eigentlich ein
anderes thema besprechen und dass das
können wir auch in anderen texten
belegen bei alles dort sind die wii ist
wie schon gesagt habe
sind die texte wo er frauen besteht
eigentlich was die texte wo er wirklich
dass wir das thematisieren will die sind
texte wo er sonst irgendwas behaupten
will
und dann kommen frauen als problem vor
oder was auch immer man könnte das sogar
es gibt eine auffällige parallele mit
den männer mit der mähne und passage in
dem kategorischen brief des filmes das
ich letzte woche besprochen habe wo sich
was genau dasselbe satz die toten von
einem tod eines mannes ist in der es in
der politik tätig zu sein die um die
tugend der frau ist auf des haushalts
aufzupassen
also da es vielleicht noch schlimmer
weil das von einer einjährigen beiden
autoren geschrieben würde aber man
könnte auch das gleiche darüber sagen
nämlich sie wollte was über die türken
sagen nichts was näheres über frauen
man könnte vielleicht sogar sagen in
dieser in dieses in diesem sinne wenn er
der benutzten ihre ideen über frauen hat
wurde da würde er das nicht in so einem
zusammenhang äußern weil es nicht der
punkt
also wenn du wenn du deine trugen lehre
vorstände ist oder dein video gewürz
lehrer dann nimmst du nicht die zeit
zehn seiten waren alle griechische
ansichten über frauen umso werfen
du gehst einfach zur sache und wenn ein
gutes beispiel nahe liegt dass zb frauen
schwächer sind als männer dann nimmst du
das entfernen gäste weiter dass ich
glaube das ist nicht unwichtig dass man
immer den zusammen wie genau wir wie wir
immer den zusammenhang und weitere
umfeld der weiblichen philosophen
bedenken sondern genauso wir diese
passagen
also nicht aus dem kontext aufreißen
aber zum glück gibt es dann passagen wo
plattform das wirklich thematisiert eine
passage ist natürlich diejenige aus der
politik die wir dann länger gesprächen
werde aber ich würde auch dazu zählen
die zwei dialoge wo wir hauptsprecher
finden die weiblich sind eine haben wir
schon besprochen das war als basia aus
dem magazin was wenn es die sich
erinnern
dort habe ich argumentiert dass das der
männer das vielleicht eine weibliche
sprecherin für diese rede ausgesucht hat
weil weibliche themen in der rede
vorgekommen sind also weil zum beispiel
die stadt athens als familie beschrieben
wird
und weil erfolg in einer erfolg der
staat dadurch erklärt wird dass eben
dass man eben diese gute familie
familiäre beziehungen zwischen den
schüssen der bevölkerung hat oder
unterhalb der bevölkerung
frage kann man auch diese als auslegung
verwenden für das andere beispiel was
viel viel berühmter ist nämlich diotima
eine herbst stärker im symposium okay
weil sie den sie posieren nicht gelesen
haben weil sie den symposien nicht
gelesen haben das erste was sie machen
sollen nach der vorlesung ist gehen und
dem symposium lesen
aber jetzt ist zu spät also kurze
beschreibung was ist was ist dieser
dialog das ist wie die titel symposiums
zusammen trinken und das ist ein treffen
von aristokraten ländern die das thema
eros gesprächen und soccer teams ist
dabei aber auch mehrere andere sogar
wichtige athener einschließlich der
dichte des dorfes jeder sodann eine rede
halten über die liebe aerosmith was er
denkt die live sein und dann gehen sie
die reihe nach und sorgt dies ist der
letzte sprecher
wenn er dann anfängt
zuerst video legt er dem letzten strecke
war er sagte dies ist und muss immer
jemanden widerlegen
aber dann könnte man sozusagen denn dann
haben wir ein problem er muss eine rege
über die liebe halten aber bekanntlich
hält sorgt hier ist keine reden er
widerlegt dass es übrigens überhaupt
nicht wahr ist erhält dauernd reden
in den dialogen aber immer mit einer
ausrede und in diesem fall ist die
aussage dass er mit zusagen die einst
die einige rede oder oder seine eigene
geräte hält sondern eine rede berichtet
die er von seiner lehrerin diotima
gehört hat und da wir jetzt sogar gesagt
sie war seine lehrerin in der kunst der
liebe nicht so wie sie jetzt denken
sondern sie hat ihm beigebracht zu
verstehen was die liebe es sei okay
wer es sie wir kennen sie aus keinen
anderen quellen und die frage stellt
sich natürlich ob sie sozusagen echt ist
also ob sie wirklich existiert hat man
könnt ihr das natürlich zweifeln weil
sie sie also er beschreibt sie als ob
sie sehr wichtige werde zum beispiel
er steigt ihr zu dass sie den athenern
erklärt haben wie sie opfern sollten und
damit haben sie die pest zehn jahre in
die zukunft
praktisch sie haben die besten zehn
jahre später gekommen als sie sonst
gewesen wäre war es sie gute beratung
gegeben hat in sachen opfern und man man
könnte man könnte sich denken einerseits
wie kann wie kann es sein dass jemand
das gemacht hat ohne anderes fenster
seien aber andererseits das irgendwie so
konkret würde platten so was erfinden
über eine eingestallt was nicht
existiert hat
also das ist so sei es schwer sei es
schwer auszulegen
ich persönlich habe überhaupt keine
ahnung der thema existiert hat würde
aber auch sagen dass es nicht so wichtig
ist in dem ich überzeugt bin dass die
reden die wir bei verschiedenen menschen
die verschiedenen stärken in den dialog
ich gehe davon aus die viennale von
platon erfunden
zum beispiel manche leute neben die
große rede vom vortag als beweis oder
beleg dafür was pro tag also der krieg
gesagt hat oder gelehrt hat meine mama
völlige princeton
das ist als ob man shakespeare nennt
nimmt um festzustellen wie eine der
fünfte gedacht hat falsch
platon ist ein künstlermarkt was erwähnt
manchmal erfindet er figuren zum
beispiel der elegische fremde ins office
ist höchstwahrscheinlich erfunden
mag man nichts peinlich ist es nicht
erfunden paar tage ist es auch nicht
erfunden aber was doch erfunden ist
meine meinung oder mindestens wer soll
eigentlich davon ausgehen im normalfall
ist es erfunden würde von ihm erfunden
ist dass das alte sprecher sagen dass es
das ist partner der das erfordert also
wenn der thema existiert hat können wir
nicht davon ausgehen dass das was wir in
ihrer rede
irgendwas mit einem mit einer ersten
damals zu tun hatte was finden wir dann
in dieser rede
passend zu ihrer juristen können
bespritzt sie zuerst sozusagen die
religiöse geologie dieses gotteshaus die
liebe und bestreitet das was alle
eigentlich schon angenommen haben und
was sagte thies auch gedacht hatte bevor
er mit dem thema geredet hatte nämlich
dass er das ein gott sagt er das ist
kein gott lautete ihr thema sondern ein
dämon was ist ein dämon ein diamond ist
sozusagen ein wesen das zwischen den den
echten gott und den menschen als
mittelmann dienst also sein vermittler
für menschen zu dem gottes zum beispiel
nimmt wenn wir opfern nimmt der diamond
die opferung den gott und um das zu
erklären beschreibt sie wie eros
gebäuden würde das gestellt das ist kurz
nachdem aphrodite gebäuden ist ist das
geschehen dass zwei andere
mit hilfe von kenia und porthos
zusammengekommen sind um das derikartz
zu beschreiben
der war ein großes fest zu feiern das
aphrodite gebäuden würde
portos liegt besoffen im garten & poor
das heißt so was wie ressorts oder
erhaben zu sein und werden per mangel
heißt also kann er ist ist weiblich
personifikation des mangels und sie
beschließt sich den besoffenen pornos zu
verführen damit sie schwanger wird und
das kind dass daraus erzeugt wird ist
dann erschoss er das ist deswegen eine
mischung aus blues und penny ressourcen
zum beispiel ist ganz geschäftsmann kann
gut nachdenken wie er an alles kommt
aber weil pannier seine mutter ist hat
hat er von haus aus sofern sie aus hat
er nichts er ist mangelhaft
er hat not sozusagen
und deswegen ist die liebe immer ein
lust irgendetwas zu haben was man das
was man nicht hat das ist sehr
interessant übrigens und hat eine lange
geschichte in der späteren philosophie
man zb denken sie daran wenn die liebe
wirklich heißt irgendwas zu wollen was
man nicht hat könnte man sie fragen ob
man immer noch verliebt ist wenn man
schon heiratet ist oder noch tiefer
inhalt für die geschichte der
philosophie konnte gott für uns kein
arrows empfinden weil er natürlich
nichts von uns braucht er hat alles und
das ist das schon interessant zu sehen
wie die lebt die liebe dann später zum
beispiel im christentum kritisiert wird
auf jeden fall
sie widerlegt socket hilfs in die in
dieser weise zeigt ihnen das dass die
liebe kann
das ist und dann beschreibt sie hin als
barfuß obdachlos will immer wissen
erwerben und klingt ziemlich wie soccer
teams kurzum also kommen viele haben
versionen ab so ausgelegt dass irgendwie
socke thies und arrows ähnliche
wegrollen des senders aus irgendeinem
grund und dann nachdem sie das erklärt
hat fängt sie an die rolle der liebe in
den menschlichen leben zu erklären und
behauptet dass alle menschen lust haben
unsterblich zu sein also für immer zu
leben und viele menschen erwerben das
dadurch dass sie dann kinder erzeugen
weil die kinder leben nach uns und staat
zum beispiel regierung so haben haben
sie kinder die kinder dann weitere
kinder haben und da wir da wird man so
sagen fortgepflanzt also man man kann
vor dauern durch fortpflanzung könnte
man sagen das ist sehr verwandt mit der
schönheit weil die schönheit ist das was
uns inspiriert diese fortpflanzung so
falls also die idee hier sein eine
schöne person
wir wollen mit den mit dieser person sex
haben damit wir fortpflanzen und
schönheit ist sozusagen ein anlass dafür
aber das ist sozusagen nur die
niedrigste stufe dieses phänomens
denn wir können uns auch dort pflanzen
oder ewig bleiben durch bessere methoden
höhere methoden zum beispiel dadurch
dass wir dass wir gute gesetze schreiben
und diese gesetze bleiben dann für die
starts pro wohnen oder für den staat für
immer hoffentlich oder mindestens
nachdem wir gestorben sind oder noch
besser können wir philosophieren und die
schönheit an sich begreifen und dann
können wir wie platon sagt geburts
schaffen in der schönheit
das ist eine sehr schöne ins berühmte
stadt ich wollte dass kurz vor lesen
also jetzt ihr thema demokratie ist es
muss nämlich der rächer auf dem
richtigen wege auf dieses ziel hin
street in seiner jugend sieht allerdings
den schönen körpern zu wenden
und zwar zuerst wenn seine führer ihn
richtig leitet einen solchen schönen
körpern lieben und an diesem sieht
furchtbar in schönen in schönen reden
erweisen
dann aber muss er nie werden dass die
schönheit an jedem einzelnen körper der
an jedem anderen körper verschwistert
ist und wenn er doch überhaupt der
schönheit der gestalt nachgehen wird
soll zur wehr ist ja größere unverstand
wenn nicht endlich die schönheit an
allen körpern vereinigen dieselbe
erkennen würde
wenn er aber zu dieser einzige land ist
dann müsse sich als liebhaber alles
schön im körper darstellen und alex pons
einer gewaltigen blut für einen einzigen
nachlassen vielmehr sie gering schätzen
und verachten
hiernach aber muss er die geistige
schönheit für weihnachten lernen als die
coty des körpers so dass wenn jemand nur
eine liebenswürdige serie besitzt mag
auch dabei sein körperlicher reiz nur
gering seien dies ihm genügt und er ist
sie liebt und
er pflegt und regengebiet und auch zu
finden sucht so wie sie geeignet sind
verrät und auf jugendliche zu wirken
diese stufe führt ihn aber wiederum nur
dazu dass er gezwungen wird das schöne
in mit den bestrebungen sitten und
gesetzen zu beachten und einzusehen dass
dies alles miteinander verwandt ist und
so dass körperliche schöne vergangenes
geringfügig 868 und zu lernen von den
beschreibungen aber muss man ihnen ist
zu den wissenschaften führen damit er
wieder um die schönheit der
wissenschaften erkenne und in dem er so
bereits auf das schöne in seiner fülle
hinblickt nichts mehr netz klassischen
sinne der schönheit im einzelnen sei es
in liebe es zu einem schnäppchen oder in
einer menschen die menschen dieser erde
oder einer vereinzelten bestrebungen
diene und sich so als model und klein
nicht erweisen sondern gleichsam auf die
höhere sie sehe des schönen hinaus
steuern und es also mit einem clique
überschlagen viel schöne und herrliche
reden und gedanken indes weit weisheits
lebensfülle gebeten hat zu deutsch
geschrieben
okay er sieht sie haben hoffentlich
verstanden worum es geht
natürlich könnten wir jetzt die ganze
vorlesung darüber zu sprechen was da los
ist will ich nichts
stattdessen will ich eine einfache frage
mich dann warum es dir thema eine frau
selbst wenn dir thema recht war also
wenn sie wirklich existiert hat hat
platon sie gewählt als sprecher und er
muss es muss eine begründung geben warum
er das gemacht hat
hinsichtlich das was ich über den lexus
gesagt habe und warum er als basis
genommen hat als halbstarker es ist
naheliegend sagen
natürlich also nicht nur das was sie
gerade gelesen habe sondern beide
hälften von der rede die tigers haben
mit weibliche themen zu tun zum beispiel
geburt leben läuft sogar aber mindestens
geburt also wie wowi heraus entstanden
ist also was ist eine familiäre
hintergrund wie es ja geboren und dann
diese diese dieses thema das wir in dem
schönen gewinn sollen
das ist sozusagen vielleicht ein thema
was man einer leicht eine leichte einer
weiblichen sprecherin zuschreiben würde
als einen mann
ich denke dass es nicht ganz falsch aber
es ist mindestens komplizierter als das
denn die ihr team us-vorschlag ist
nichts so sagen denkt wie eine typische
frau denkt nur an die familie und
angebot also wenn wir wirklich denken
frau ist gleich geburt und familie dann
das ist natürlich nichts was die achimer
sagen werden was die sun will und das
ist der grund dafür dass diese lange
passagen vorgelesen habe was ich sagen
will es genau dass das nur die
niedrigste stufe ist dieses versuchs die
schönheit zu begreifen oder in dem
schönen zu gebären
dass es zb gesetze zu schreiben noch
besser ist die schönheit an sich zu
verstehen also bloß getragen und
deswegen könnte man fragen wenn platz
und ansicht war eine frau zu nehmen weil
er wusste dass er susann was weibliches
thematisieren wollte dann müssen wir
auch sagen das hat er irgendwie zu
umgedreht dadurch dass er eine frau
nimmt um zu zeigen
das geburts also ein normales geburt
kann nicht mehr falsches geburtsdatum
wirklich kinderkriegen ist nicht genug
übrigens könnte man hier auch erwähnen
dass also ein thema was sehr oft in
dieser passage vorkommt ist das wenn in
einer beziehung zwischen einem älteren
griechischen man in einem jungen
griechen mann ist der held zelle dafür
zuständig den jungen den jungen mann zur
weisheit zu bringen oder in dieppe ins
politische leben zu bringen und das
taucht bei platon auf in der art und
weise dass der ältere mann dem jungen
mann hält zu philosophieren zum beispiel
sockels und und den schülern mit dem er
mit seiner seite verbracht hat und in
einem anderen in dem ca täters wird
sortiert als hebamme beschrieben
also dieses spiel etwas platt gemacht wo
er keine sorge die seinen männlichen
figur beschreibt ihn als frau als eine
hebamme umfasst genau diese dieses
prozesses zu beschreiben also diese die
idee dass meine füße fiel
als eine art geburts zu verstellen er
ist durchaus fähig dieses thema mit
einem mann zu reduzieren nämlich sockel
stieß
also ist komplizierter als nur geburt
deswegen frau aber ich glaube trotzdem
hat er hat er dir thema als sprecherin
gewählt teilweise woher er wollte diese
diese art fortpflanzung zusammenhänge zu
fragen und auch in frage zu stellen
und er dachte das wäre dann stärker wenn
die sprechenden die das macht weiblich
ist
also es werden eine vermutung natürlich
kann ich das nicht beweisen aber ich
würde mindestens und das hätte ich auch
nicht veröffentlichen
aber ich denke es ist mindestens gut
wenn man die rede der diotima liest man
soll sozusagen die ganze zeit überlegen
warum ich meine es gibt nicht so viele
frauen in den dialogen warum haben wir
hier erreicht hier eine frau so
interessante frei und das ist meine frau
fragen oder weißt du denn bevor die
politik gespräche sie sind alle so
gespannt auf die politik
es wird keine weitere minute warten das
ist schön hoffentlich haben sie all die
polit er gelesen wenn nicht das zweite
was sie machen nach der vorlesung nach
dem symposion gelesen haben ist die
politiker zu lesen
sie sollen mit dem symposium anfangen
weil er kürzer ist und auch ein bisschen
lustiger aber die polizei ist wirklich
natürlich ein toller text sehr reich und
auch sehr lang besteht aus zehn büchern
wovon unsere passage im fünften buch
vorkommt und hier sind wir tief
mittendrin im sommer dieses versuch den
perfekten starts zu beschreiben denn die
kalle pohl es also die perfekte oder
haben staats oder staat im staat oder
start weil ich mein polit er heißt dass
sowas wie staat aber in diesem fall bei
den griechen kontext ist das ist
wirklich eine stadt wie athen zb okay so
macht er das kompliziert aber kurz was
er machen möchte es zeigen dass die tour
im allgemeinen und die gerechtigkeit im
besonderen nichts
ist es hilfreich oder vorteilhaft für
die menschheit
das müssen wir zeigen weil er im ersten
buch gegen einen festen haben ist super
kurs argumentiert untersee mikus
behauptet dass die trüben ist sozusagen
haben eine lüge ist die uns dazu bringen
soll nicht das nehmen was für uns
vorteilhaft ist also seine idee ist dass
wir sozusagen die gerechtigkeit sondern
das durchschauen man sehen dass das so
sein alles eintritt lässt
das soll die stärkeren dann irgendwie
kontrollieren diese diese idee der
gerechtigkeit und dann sagt sollten sie
es nein gerechtigkeit ist doch
vorteilhaft für alle menschen und um das
zeigen stellt er vor dass wir die
gerechtigkeit plätze besser verstehen
können wenn wir sie groß geschrieben
lesen könnten statt in kleinen
buchstaben also die idee ist groß
geschrieben ist die stadt weil oder der
staat weil er der stadt sehr groß ist im
gegensatz zu dem einzelnen menschen und
dann nachdem wir die gerechtigkeit die
politische gerechtigkeit beschworen
haben sind wir dann bereits die
individuelle gerechtigkeit zu besprechen
okay gut dann erklärt er wie es in dem
perfekten start läuft und es ist sehr
detailliert und sehr grundlegend für
seine politische politische theorie ist
dass wir zwei schichten haben wir haben
sozusagen das die normale bevölkerung
eigentlich die handwerker und bauern und
über diese schicht gibt es die wette die
sind die soldaten
und es wird sehr lang beschrieben wie
die märkte ausgebildet werden die sollen
die sind wie hunde
das wäre es gesagt also die die wollen
alles tun um ihr um daten gehe es zu
verteidigen
genau wie ein hund alles um den herrchen
mit hula hoop und das herrliche den
händen das herrchen zu verteidigen und
so weiter und dann sagt er wieder heim
passt dass die vector alle kinder
gemeinsam erzielen werden
aber dann geht er einfach weiter und
dann kommen wir zum anfang des fünften
buches wenn dann sagt einer von seinen
zwei gesprächspartner hat jemand ist
unklar
übrigens die zwei gesprächspartner sind
die brüder platons alimente simplon team
anders sagt hayes oder otis du hast
behauptet dass die alle kinder gemeinsam
erzogen werden von allen rechten das
dass du damit gemeint und dann sagt sagt
das ist eigentlich schwieriges thema und
wir werden ein bisschen lächerlich
scheinen erscheinen wenn wir das
besprechen aber warum nicht
und dann fängt er an zu erklären welche
maßnahmen sie in den perfekten starts
haben würden wenn es um frauen und
erziehung geht also ich haben wir
endlich eine passage wo er wirklich
ausdrücklich unser thema geschlecht was
sagt er
ok sehr überraschend und also ich denke
bei dieser passage soll man nie
vergessen dass man das dass das würde
für aristokratische griechische männer
geschrieben wie alles dort ließ also
leute für wen die ist einfach
selbstverständlich war dass frauen im
haushalt bleiben dass nur männer
politisch tätig sind dass frauen
natürlich nie im krieg tätig sind usw
das erste was er sagt ist frauen werden
auch soldaten seien bürger wenn wir
männliche wächter haben dann müssen wir
weibliche werte haben das sind sozusagen
die nur die weibliche mitglieder dieser
gesellschaftlichen schicht und übrigens
basel vergesse das wetter so sagen diese
obere schicht wird später dann
aufgesplittet war marie rektorin gewählt
die philosophen unter den wächtern die
die philosophisch gibt begabt sind die
denn ausgebildet und die werden die
könige also die die für der status und
wir können davon entnehmen dass in dem
perfekten start
das platt plattform oder laub kreativen
mindestens dass es auch weibliche
förderungen in der perfekten start geben
wird wenn er wenn er zuerst sagt es wird
auch weibliche rechte geben oder
und sie müssen genau so zitiert sein sie
müssen auch nachts mit den männlichen
möchten trainieren oder gymnasium wie
sie alle wahrscheinlich wissen heißt ein
ort wo man nachts sport2 kinos heißt na
und das klingt zwar lächerlich aber soll
so ist das also wenn wir wenn wir bald
liche märkte haben sollen dann müssen
sie genauso behandelt werden wie die
wette und das haben wir alles über die
männliche möchte gesagt deswegen werden
die werke rennen auch so es so
funktioniert und klarkommen sagt ja ja
ja ja aber dann kommen sie darauf dass
das wahrscheinlich sehr lächerlich
klingt also noch mal wenn sie vor als
dort ließ ließ das und denkt vielleicht
sogar dass deshalb dass das ein scherz
ist also es kann mir sehr gut vorstellen
dass ein typischer leser im alten land
das lesen würde und würde sich totlachen
und vielleicht hat traten auch sogar
gefolgt dass das irgendwie lustig ist
wobei es auch anscheinend er
gemeint ist denn dann versuchst sorgt
ist das alles zu begründen
und das macht er insofern dass er sagt
wenn wir verschiedene funktionen
verschiedenen menschen zu teilen denn
nur weil sie von der natur aus
verschiedenen sims zum beispiel mache es
sinn von der natur aus begabt herz des
werden und manche nichts also sozusagen
von der natur aus natürlich die mögliche
ärzte zu lassen ärzte zu werden und dann
sagt er
es könnte aber durchaus nahrung geben
die auch diese damen hätten hätten und
dann wäre es irgendwie blöd sind sie
nichts zu erlauben ärztinnen zu werden
und genauso wird es her dass plan geben
die kriegerisch und sogar philosophisch
sind hier ist die passage das ist auf
dem handy
hoffentlich ja keines der geschäfte
ausdehnen die verwaltung des staates
besteht kommt einer frau zu weil sie
frau oder einem mann weil er man ist
sondern die begabungen sind unter beide
geschlechter gleicher weise verteilt in
allen geschaffen hat das habe ich
vergessen zu ändern hat die frau an
allen der man naturgemäß anteil bei
allem habe ist die frau schwächer als
der mann
es klang ganz gut bis dann oder
die letzte ist die letzte blase okay was
ist hier das argument was ja behaupten
will ist es gibt schon eine natürliche
unterscheiden zwischen männern frauen
aber sie besteht hauptsächlich dadurch
dass frauen kinder kriegen und wenn er
nichts und das hat nichts zum beispiel
mit krieg oder philosophie oder sonst
irgendwas zu tun und wir werden gehen
immer genau die gleiche begabungen im
unterhalt den frauen sind die wir unter
hat den männern sehen auch englisch
verteilt und deswegen ist sozusagen eine
verlust- fenster des staates wenn wir
das nicht ausnutzen würden zum beispiel
wenn es fragen gibt es die vielen
kleinen wäre es blöd sind das nicht zu
erlauben nur weil sie frauen sind weil
man oder frau sein hat nichts damit zu
tun
es gibt so seien frauen die einer die
einer philosophischen natur sind genau
wie männer
dann gibt es männer die nicht
philosophisch sind nicht vergessen die
große mehrheit der bevölkerung besteht
aus diesen dieser unterklasse also diese
diese wette rennen sind von haus aus
besser als all die neuner die handwerker
sind aber anscheinend nicht so gut wie
die männliche möchte und deswegen sagt
er
dieses gesetz nämlich ist das gesetz das
frauen auch besser sein werden und auch
für firmen und auch reagieren werden
das ist optimal für den staat wie sollen
wir das alles bewerten
wie gesagt das ist natürlich erstaunt
das müssen wir wirklich sagen das ist
wirklich erstaunlich aber andererseits
das ist nichts gerade feministisch in
unserem sinne wie das gesagt hat dass
das werden wir ganz gut
daher ist jetzt übersetzen
mein enkel ist ganz gut oder wobei wenn
sie ein engel tische akzente gewohnt
sind vielleicht doch nicht
also es kam ein falsches argument zu
behaupten das paar fragen kein
besonderes gebiet haben weil männer
überall besser sind und das war sehr
sagt also bei jeder tätigkeit können
männer frauen übertreffen
aber bei jeder tätigkeit sind frauen
sind dabei also diesen zweiten platz
aber die sind mindestens im rennen
das ist sagen das ist so sollen die die
eine schlechte nachricht
eine weitere schlechte nachricht und ich
glaube das ist wirklich interessant ist
noch was seines worauf das aufmerksam
gemacht hat hier geht es gar nicht darum
dass wir frauen liebe rationen oder
realisation ihre möglichkeiten zwecks
ihre individuellen vollkommen 1 in auge
haben
das hat gar nichts damit zu tun also
dass nicht wie bei alters dort ließ bei
einer sorte knees hat man den eindruck
ziel der politik ist eine situation zu
kreieren wodurch jeder einzelne bürger
seine fähigkeit völlig realisieren kann
das ist hier nicht der punkt
der punkt hier ist der staat soll
erfolgreich sein und zwar so erfolgreich
wie möglich und wenn wir nicht alle mann
sind im mittel nutzen um dieses ziel zu
erreichen wird die stadt weniger
erfolgreich als sie ist sein oder wird
der staat weniger erfolgreich sein als
er sein könnte das werde ich sozusagen
verschwenderisch es wäre als ob man zum
beispiel gut so leven bäume hat und kein
olivenöl daraus machen würden und
ähnlicher weise könnte man sagen
vielleicht hat man zwei arten von anita
olivenbäume in dem in einer stadt eine
art olivenbaum produziert besseres
erleben weil als die andere art aber
trotzdem würde man die zweite art
olivenbaum nicht einfach ignorieren und
kein öl daraus machen
man würde es auch nehmen und auch
produzieren und wo es nicht ganz so gut
ist
die frauen sind den schlächter den
bäumen ähnlich das hatte ich gerade
erfunden war vielleicht keine gute idee
und ist natürlich nicht meine meinung
sondern platons
also die idee ist man hat diese man hat
dieses ressorts und wenn man das oder
eigenmittel oder potenzielle mitteln
könnte man sagen man hat begabte
menschen und es egal ob sie frau oder
mann sind man muss sie man muss sie
entwickeln und ausbilden und erzielen
damit man das beste daraus macht und wir
haben übrigens eine ähnliche stelle in
den lakers diesem späteren die ahnung wo
er praktisch sagt wir sollen frauen für
eine breite auswahl an möglichen
tätigkeiten benutzen damit wir ja kein
keine mittel verschwendet
also einerseits ist es nicht fantastisch
weil er immer noch behauptet dass frauen
nicht so kurzem die männer zweiten ist
es nicht realistisch weil feminismus in
unserer zeit geht es darum dass frauen
wegen weil sie ihre einzelne freiheit
genießen können so sein oder ausnutzen
können sie müssen erlaubt werden
alles aus sich zu machen was sie können
wegen wählen sie reden hier einig also
wegen dieser frau immerhin sie sind also
die frauen die hier an der uni sind
unter anderem sie die breit ich sind sie
sind nicht hier damit die juni eine
bessere uni ist uns auch wahrscheinlich
alles ist natürlich diskutabel
aber wahrscheinlich sehen sind das nicht
so ich bin erlaubt hier an der uni seien
damit deutschland stärker ist sie sind
er hier an der uni weiß sie ein besserer
mensch sein bruder service oder
sehe man hier um das vaterland zu
stärken wahrscheinlich mit ich glaube
eines rechts also wenn man so einen
paten als der minister stellen will muss
man diese zwei gegenargumente ersten
ersten ernst nehmen allerdings würde ich
nochmal betonen
obwohl er sagt bei jeder tätigkeit ist
die frau schlechter als der mann
es ist offensichtlich dass diese frauen
die sie wächterinnen die auch
philosophieren können und die auch
königin werden können
dies sind bei weitem das er als die
meisten männer in der in den staat nur
nie ganz so gut wie die
spitzenkandidaten nehmen die ähnliche
männer also sie können daraus machen was
sie wollen
es ist klar dass die sozusagen die
bestmögliche menschen immer männlich
sind habe die man könnt ihr vielleicht
sagen dass die zweit dass die menschen
mag diese passage frauen sind und die
sind vorne viele viele bäcker ok also
wie aufgeklärt ist das alles ja ist
alles platt uns meinung hätte ich das
hier schreiben sollen am anfang
würde man denken aber ich glaube gute
guter punkt aber ich denke plattform
würde so sehen was er argumentiert ist
jede tätigkeit muss von den menschen
erfüllt werden oder ausgeübt werden von
den menschen die dafür begabungen haben
und es gibt dann frauen die begabt sind
zu regieren
und anscheinend und begab sich zu
philosophieren
ein problem hier ist das fluss also wenn
man dann weiterhin der polit er liest
hat man sehr den eindruck dass klasse 4
und weisheit ist sozusagen ganz oder gar
nichts also man tut sich schwer das zu
verstehen wie er sein könnte dass manche
philosophen die formen begreifen und
dadurch verständlich sie den staat
regieren können
und manche andere philosophen machen
genau dasselbe können auch regieren aber
diese das als diese das ist schwer zu
begreifen und man muss auch zugeben dass
er betrunken nichts dass frauen dabei
sind wenn wir dann diese weitere stufe
erreichen aber gespickt ist nicht sehr
lang aber es ist offensichtlich der fall
weil sie sozusagen überall der wahl da
beißen in dieser oper entschied also es
muss es geben aber ich würde ich
zustimmen das an wenn man wenn man
philosophen als vollkommene menschen
versteht dann tut man sich schwer zu
verstehen wie frauen irgendwie ein
bisschen schlechter sind in dieser
hinsicht als männer
es ist schon ein problem am andere
fragen über werde jetzt alles besprechen
also jetzt wäre die zeit fragen zu
platzen bevor es viel schlimmer wird
[Musik]
ja ja ja natürlich also wenn man diese
kritik nie alles dann immer was das
anders sagt ist richtig aber sie sind
nur so seien eine eine warnung dass
nicht noch weiter zunehmen als platt und
wirklich gekommen ist sozusagen und
außerdem ein für mich ist das der punkt
hier ist nicht sozusagen punkte zu
vergeben
und als ob diese einen dreier zu geben
oder vielleicht einen fünften platz und
jetzt ein zweier jemand das würden wir
vielleicht tun wenn wir punkte gehen
würde
kriegt die polit er zwei millionen
aber das ist nicht der punkt der punkt
ist zu verstehen was war die breite der
möglichen einstellungen frauen gegenüber
in dieser zeit nichts unter anderem weil
das wie sie nächste wie wir nächste
woche sein werden
das bildet wirklich den hintergrund für
die philosophin der spätantike weil die
andere alle für das auch in eine
spätantike trat sondern alles wirklich
sehr ernsthaft gelesen haben also die
erwarten zum beispiel die idee dass
frauen philosophieren können
es ist auffällig dass wir das wir wissen
dass es weibliche plateau mieterinnen
gegeben hat aber keine weibliche
aristotelischen
und das ist kein zufall dass hat mit den
texten zu tun würde ich mindestens
einnehmen sollte super wie gesagt gibt
es eigentlich zwei arten von passage die
wir hier in betrieb nehmen können
einerseits passagen aus der biologischen
werken die niemand liest eigentlich
obwohl das eine
das werde ein großer großer teil der
werke des dort ließ denn es gibt viel
psychologische werkes aristoteles und
diesen alle ziemlich lang also die sind
leider zum beispiel als ein dutzend
werke die der anima oder sowas
also es gibt das einerseits andererseits
gibt es dann diese stellen in der
politik und internet marketing wo er
frauen besser geschwächt
okay was sagt ja in diesen zwei
verschiedenen arten von text in der
biologische geologischen werke der
bildungswerken kommen frauen eigentlich
vor
innerhalb seiner fortpflanzungs theorie
zum beispiel will er erklären wieso es
ist dass wir überhaupt weibliche kinder
haben
wie kommt das bei es kommt ziemlich
regelmäßig vor ein bisschen ein bisschen
mehr als die hälfte der zeit und als
guter biologin also ist das erklären
antwort es gibt wenn ein kind schon
immer noch in der mutter so nennt noch
bei wickeln lässt ist die hauptsache
hauptsächliche begründung für die
fortentwicklung hitze es gibt materie
in der mutter das ist eigentlich blut
wahrscheinlich und man könnte sagen das
blut wir verkocht und soll dann zu tun
entwickeln fast wie ein kuchen und wenn
alles gut läuft hat man ein männliches
kind wenn die hitze etwas mangelhaft ist
dann bekommt man manchmal eine frau also
wir können wirklich buch stell mir sagen
frauen sind also diese meinung nach
müssten um ihre männer und nun aber wenn
die seiten noch mal wenn ich seine
frauen und männer
dass das stimmt aber das geht ja alle
hier nicht nur das ist wirklich eine
theorie der weiblichkeit im gegensatz
zur menschlichkeit so ein bisschen
komplizierter ist das aber das
eigentlich seine idee das ist dir
erklären wie könnte man das begründen
vielleicht hat würde sagen ja man kann
empirisch feststellen dass männer wärmer
sind also buchstäblich wärme dass sie
kennen das wahrscheinlich alle dass
frauen oft kalte hände haben also ich
weiß nicht wer das gedacht hat natürlich
in einer zeit wo frauen öfter zu hause
geblieben wären werden sie blasser
gewesen
weniger aktiv also er hat es gibt auch
gesellschaftliche gründe warum er
vielleicht meinen würde dass frauen
weniger um haben also wer der hitze
sozusagen weniger energie das alles nur
spekulation alles auf jeden fall das was
er über das die erzeugung der weiblichen
tieren sagt aber das ist nichts
irgendwie nichts passt nicht das
schlimmste
noch schlimmer ist seine erklärung der
rolle der frau in fortpflanzen nämlich
wir brauchen also sie wissen
wahrscheinlich war das jahres dort ließ
jedes substanz zum beispiel ein mensch
oder ein pferd besteht aus zwei aspekten
materie vor zum beispiel ist man könnte
sagen dass es entweder mein und mein
körper
obwohl oder vielleicht die materielle
zutaten woraus mein körper besteht zum
beispiel knochen und blut oder
vielleicht die vier elemente
schlussendlich dann vor
das ist natürlich die seele nach der
theorie sei das noch mal
das hat nichts mit frauen zu tun aber es
tut gut zu merken
die hsbc das ist seine sein symbolisches
werk ganz bewusst haben die lebendigen
bestimmt gelesen wenn leute der heime
lesen denken haben sie irgendwie immer
im kopf ich lese hier eine theorie über
die menschliche seele und wenn nicht
menschliche geist falsch dass eine
theorie der seele und jedes leben das
ding hat eine ganze tiere und menschen
nur im zwölften buch woher die die
nationale fähigkeit alles das denken nur
dort wo er das betrifft das nur die
menschen
und man kann sogar sagen dass der aal
immer über die serie
das ist eigentlich der die grundlegende
erklärung für die psychologische man
auch auf jeden fall was sagt er dann zur
rolle der frau und mann im
frau war also die frau und das das hat
mit menstruation und so weiter zu tun
also die frau bietet die materie und die
form kommt von seite der des mannes dass
es in der in seinem samen anwesend wie
genau er hat eine theorie über
bewegungen die in dieser flüssigkeit
anwesend sind wenn die bewegungen in
diese materie hinein kommen dann setzen
sie die materie in bewegung und dann
fängt diese hätten an und hat und das
blut oder die materie wird gekocht und
dann entstehen daraus dass materielle
sind komplizierter als das anders das
grob die idee und viele viele leser
haben nicht unser weg hier gesehen das
ist sozusagen die eine fundamentale
erklärung für frauenfeindlichkeit passiv
kann nichts tun aktiv müssen alles tun
und so weiter okay das also schlimmer
kann man das mit beschreiben ist es
wirklich so schlimm
vielleicht nichts
ja ja es ist natürlich nicht meine
meinung
ok erster ist hat er offensichtlich ein
problem nämlich kinder sind oft der
mutter ähnlich also wenn die wenn die
mutter nur die materie anbietet und die
vor
also alles was zusammen diesen einzelnen
mensch oder tier definiert wenn es als
den mann kurz wie kann es sein dass zum
beispiel klavier oder schöne frauen
kraftwerk werde oder schöne kinder haben
hat es soll ich weiß das sehr gut
nun versucht das zu erklären also
erscheint anzunehmen dass die materie
auch kinos charakter hat dass die frau
auch was den kindern geben kann und
deswegen könnte man sagen dass das
gefährlichste sagen das ist wirklich nur
so alles wird von dem handgemacht und
essen nur sozusagen eine prozent sanität
nein reine potenzial i tät ist gar
nichts das ist was echtes was in der end
der mutter als körperliche substanz
anwesend ist es ist nicht egal von
welcher von welcher mutter du kommst
weil nicht die materie die jede frau
liefert ist anders anscheinend das ist
ein aspekt ein weiteres aspekt ist man
muss sich fragen ob es wirklich nach der
ästhetischen theorie sein kann dass
frauen nichts mehr nichts mehr als
unvollkommen in männer sind denn seine
theorie der natur ist dass die natur
teleologische ist das alles in der natur
ein zweck erfüllt alles hat eine
funktion und wenn alles gut läuft wird
diese funktion erfüllt und oft sagt das
warten ist die natur ist das was immer
passiert
jetzt oder hauptsächlich also fast immer
vielleicht könnte man sagen die es gibt
natürlich immer ausnahmen es gibt geld
geburts und wert mit nur drei beine oder
so was aber für ascot ließ dass das zelt
nicht als natürlich genau weil es nicht
immer oder hauptsächlich ist fast nie
kommt es vor dass ein tier mit einem
wänden beim geboren wird und deswegen
zählt das sozusagen nichts zur natur ist
das gehört nicht zur theologischen
ordnung der natur aber frauen weibliche
tiere im allgemeinen das sind die hälfte
der bevölkerung
also man kann nicht sagen da das ist nur
eine ausnahme eine frau sprang der hitze
das ist wie wenn ein pferd nur drei
bayern ein es kann nicht sein das ist
wirklich nur weiß nichts weiß ja oft
vorkommt die hatte derzeit vorkommt
sondern wir brauchen das unbedingt weil
wenn wir keine weibliche tiere haben
haben wir keine tiere nach einer
generation also das musste sein von der
naturgewalt sein
dass es weitergeht er ist es kann nicht
nur so seien aus versehen sein
von seite der natur nicht dass natur
plant wir sind nicht wie gott aber
natürlich hat jede zweite
sagen wir es so man kann das als eine
spannung innerhalb seiner theorie sehen
man könnte auch sagen dass wenn wenn er
sagt immer oder fast immer oder immer
oder meistens was er damit meint ist
nichts zusammen statistisch sondern
normativ also normativ sind menschen
männlich aber die hälfte der zeit nichts
da könnte man auch die beobachtung
machen das passt wirklich eine weitere
theorie hat die wahrscheinlich noch
skandalöse ist als das was ich gesagt
habe nämlich über sklaven und das ist er
mit seiner frau und harry verwandt er
behauptet das klima eine sehr starke
rolle in der entwicklung eines menschen
hat und dass wenn man in einer
schlechten klima aufwächst dass man
nichts in der lage ist die vernunft
einzusetzen gut und tugendhaft zu leben
wo ist die gute klima
griechenland wo ist die schlechte klima
die restliche welt weniger also außerdem
mittel mittelmeer gebiet also in person
zb sind alle menschen barbaren und
natürlich sagt dass bahn natürliche
sklaven sind wenn man muss nicht lang
denken zusehen dass nach dieser theorie
die große mehrheit der menschen
sklavisch fans also sowieso die die
große mehrheit die hälfte der menschen
die sind sowieso frauen und dann noch
dazu sind alle die nicht wissen sklaven
oder sollen das baden seien die brauchen
einen her damit sie tugendhaft und
richtig leben können die brauchen
fördern und mag ich jetzt alles beliebte
das ist nochmals eine erklärung für die
tatsachen die erste saison in seiner
gesellschaft gefunden hat warum denken
wir die griechen das es erlaubt es war
dann einfach im krieg zu entführen und
sie der der sklaverei setzte weil sie
als natürliches klaren sind es ist eine
erklärung für sozusagen gebraucht hätten
unter den griechen und ist auch sogar
wissenschaftlich begründet durch seine
klimatechnologie also nochmal kann
können wir sagen erscheinen würde er
nicht unbedingt behaupten dass der
natürliche zustand der zustand ist der
bart immer vorkommt obwohl er schon
diesen mit diesem spruch hat immer oder
meistens meistens sind menschen
mangelhaft laut alles dort ließ das war
übrigens auch für planung der fall des
in den perfekten start war es so gut
läuft wie es kann haben wir eine kleine
kleine obere schicht beide geschlechter
und dann eine grössere unterschicht
elitär ismus ist sowieso dabei arbeite
okay das bildet als hintergrund für das
was in der ethik und in der politik sagt
in der hektik sagt er nicht viel über
frauen aber was er schon sagt ist das
also eine interessante stelle kommt und
ist ein gutes beispiel von der art und
weise die frauen manchmal der
philosophie als thema vorkommen
er ist eigentlich dabei was anderes zu
besprechen noch mal nämlich seine
freundschaft theorie und laut seiner
freundschafts handy können können leute
nur perfekt befreundet sein wenn sie
gleichwertig sind
er hat so lang seiner theorie gibt es
verschiedene arten von freundschaft und
die beste freunde die perfekte freunde
sind freunde die wie genetische
charakter befreundet sind zb ihr habt
die tugend und sie auch deswegen sind
wir gute freunde also wir schätzen eine
uns gegenseitig wegen des charakters
man kann auch aus anderen gründen
befreundet sein
zum beispiel als vergnügen oder
ausnutzen aber das ist kein vollkommen
keine vollkommene freundschaft
vollkommene freundschaft kann nicht
entstehen wenn ein freund tugendhafte
ist als der andere war der 1
weil er würde nie den anderen so
schätzen wie gegenseitig es muss gleich
fertig sein und dann sagt er
ja das ist der grund warum männer und
frauen nichts keine perfekte freunde
sein können oder warum ein ehemann mit
seiner elf damit perfekt befreundet ich
als geplant ist jetzt ins tal
es gibt nichts wäre nächste woche wird
es besser
also einmal keine elfen mit perfekte
freunde sein weil sie nicht gleichwertig
sein können auch können wir nicht
freundin mit gott sein weil gott dass er
es als wir und er dass sein beispiel das
klingt ziemlich schlecht und vielleicht
noch schlimmer ist eine andere passage
im gleichen buch der der ethik als auch
im achten buch wo er sagt die
beziehungen innerhalb eines hauses
ähnelt die beziehung innerhalb eines
staates wo ich man kann einen start in
verschiedenen weisen organisieren
in manchen staaten haben wir fast alles
zu kratie das heißt der gärung der
besseren oder der das den besten der
besten
und das so ist es im haus der ehemannes
der beste also er regiert über die das
haus und die frau desto kritisch sie
muss ihm folgen
praktisch allerdings gibt es dann
tätigkeiten die für sie angemessen sind
und in diesem gebiet also war diese
haushalts sachen reagiert sie dass es
sie übergibt er liebe gibt hier die
macht in die kompetenz zu regieren
das ist was wie ein unter führer zu sein
die wichtigste ist alles aber in der
politik das ist kurz am ende des ersten
buches und hier hat hat ja schon dass
seine sklaverei tiere die schon
besprochen und dann kommt er dazu die
des haushalts zu besprechen das werden
wir auch nächste woche übrigens
gesprächen haushalts theorie aber kurz
gibt es für alle drei ebenen in der
praktischen fluss wie es gibt zig das
ist für den mensch der individuelle für
den individuellen mensch dann gibt es
ganz oben
der staat das ist das team das er
bespricht man politik also politik ist
eine gestaltung des staates und in der
mitte gibt es ökonomisch das kommt von
dem gläschen wodka wie schon gesagt
glaube ich also ökonomie der ökonomik
erst die studie des haushalts
ursprünglich deswegen sagt er hier ein
bisschen darüber
nun fragt sich die es wie die beziehung
zwischen den verschiedenen mitglieder
des haushalts fusioniert es gibt den
ehemann
die ehefrau die haussklaven und die
kinder und es gibt beziehungen zwischen
allen diesen gruppen und über jede
natürlich jetzt der immer noch mal und
er hat eine andere art regierung über
die verschiedene andere mitglieder des
haushalts über die frau reagiert er hier
nicht aristokratisch sondern politik aus
das heißt politikers normalerweise heißt
politikers zum beispiel in athen dass
all die bürger gemeinsam die police wer
hier also hier klingt er es als ob alles
okay sagen möchte der die ehefrau und
der ehemann regieren des haushalt
zusammen
endlich
aber dann sagt er mit 1 mit einem
unterschied nämlich in einer police
können die leute abwechselnd die an die
macht kommen zum beispiel die generale
oder was auch immer diese die diese
offiziere die kommen in athen beliebige
werden sie ausgewählt um das eine
bestimmte zeit zu treiben also diese
diese so einem markt stelle band kind
haushalt ist der ehemann immer an der
macht und die fh kommt nicht mehr an
dass es diese praktischen die daten über
handy ans ohr hält das pferd das als
eine eine politik hoss beziehung oder
eine beziehung beschreibt die politik
ausgeübt wird oder ausgeführt wird dass
es vielleicht besser als das was in der
ethik sagt dann kommt er dazu zu fragen
ob alle mitglieder des haushalts
tugendhaft sein können weil sei nicht
seine idee ist der ehemann muss sein und
er muss irgendwie dafür
er muss schauen dass das ganze haushalt
funktioniert also eine idee werde alle
mitglieder des haushalts müssen die
kurve setzten und irgendwie stimmt dass
es im sinne von die müssen alle ihre
fähigkeiten und tätigkeiten richtig
ausführt sie müssen sozusagen tun hat
tun das was sie wofür sie da sind die
sklaven massenhaft dem hausherr folgen
und gehörten aber es wäre natürlich
falsch wenn die sklaven versuchen würden
ihre eigenen sind einige entscheidungen
zu treffen wichtige entscheidungen weil
sie nicht dafür fähig sind
wie steht es mit der frau die einbindung
der satz können die sklaven und die
fragen zu besetzen
ja aber in einer anderen weise als der
ehemann dan ist auf dem handy dem
sklavenmarkt die fähigkeit des
überlegens politikern gänzlich die frau
hat sie zwar also die fähigkeit zu
überlegen oder sie denken oder so
entscheiden ist hat sie zwar aber
akkurat dass ein griechisches wort
das heißt dann das heißt so etwas wie
und kontrolliert oder nichts mit
dominanz oder irgend sowas
und das würde verschiedene ausgelegt von
verschiedenen für deswegen habe ich das
nicht übersetzt es ist nicht wahr genau
was das heißen soll eine idee ist hier
vernunft ist nicht in der lage ihre
emotionen zu beherrschen aber das kind
sehr unwahrscheinlich weil die ganze
idee ist dass sie unter sicht des
hausherrn tugendhaft agieren kann und
nicht zu vergessen in der ethik hat
sogar gesagt in ihrem gebiet also bei
ihren sachen ist sie sie regiert also es
kann nicht sein dass sie sozusagen
unkontrolliert ist das kann nicht die
idee sein
ich denke die idee ist sie ist accor an
weil sie nur innerhalb des haushalts
regieren darf als sie sie es nicht
sozusagen die höchste aktualität die
anwesen ist
das ist der mann und ich würde das so
übersetzen heißt so etwas wie kohle
aktualität parcours als aber auch auf
dem handy
also die ihre palette ihre politik on
also ihre entscheidungsfähigkeit ist
nicht so weit entwickelt dass sie zb
politisch agieren kann und auch nicht so
weit entwickeln dass sie sozusagen auch
eine ebene ist mit mit dem man aber
alles was er hier begründen will ist er
will nicht begründen das brauen
unvernünftig sense oder sowas oder von
den emotionen irgendwie unterworfen oder
sowas
was er bekommen will ist warum sie den
zweiten platz oder den zweiten autorität
innerhalb des hausrats sein als er den
erkennen warum die tastatur des
haushalts ist so wie es ist denke ich
leider würde die stadt nicht unbedingt
immer so ausgelegt in den späteren in
der stadt ist okay dann zeit für eine
frage oder 2 zum beispiel wenn der
ehemann stirbt und die l frau ja gute
frage das ist verschieden in
verschiedenen phasen der ein tipp für
die frage was passiert in einem haushalt
wenn der mann stirbt
das ist eigentlich die frage welche
juristische rechte hat eine frau und
dass es verschieden zu einer beantworten
je nachdem in welcher phase der antike
wir sind aber in athen zb ich denke dass
es zufall dass juristische rechte einer
frau müssten durch einen mann ausgeübt
werden also sie muss ihren vater oder
onkel oder so jemand holen um es sicher
dass sie ihr selbst behalten darf oder
soll aber eine erwachsene erwachsenen
waren
in anderen phasen der antiken geschichte
schaut es besser aus zb der römischen
sei es manchmal
also das ist natürlich eine frage über
die geschichte des rechts habe ich eine
gute schlage okay sonst bleiben
ok nächste woche wenn wir die texte aus
der spätantike beschränken aber
hauptsächlich wenn wir uns auf für das
sofa aus der spätantike schrecken also
aus der römischen zeit vor allem
[Musik]